GAVEL IS NOW ON
SENATE BUDGET FSCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO
MANAGE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RISKS THE SENATE CONTINUES TO
WELCOME THE PUBLIC AND HAS
PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
PARTICIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE IS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. BUT TODAY IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO IT IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. ANYONE
WHO MAY BE COME DISRUPTIVE WILL
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOVED FROM
THE MEETING OR HAVE THEIR-
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. OF
THE COMPOUND TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY GREATLY HELP IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED DID
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR.
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE. WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE AB ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A TELECONFERENCE ERVAS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED BEFORE WE
BEGIN DR BACK BILL WELL WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR AZAM HERE
SENATOR ALTHOUGH PRESENT SENATOR
GROW. SENATOR CORTEZ ANY CENTER
COURTESY PRESIDENT SENATOR
NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN PRESENT
THE CORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR ONLY A DISCUSSION ITEM TODAY
ISSUE FIFTY FIVE- THAT IS THE
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
INTEROPERABLE COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM AND WE WILL HAVE OUR L.
A. ILL INTRODUCE THE PROPOSAL
AFTER R. L. A. ILL WE WILL HEAR
FROMSCOTT IT'S AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LA. RICS L. A. R. I.
C. S. AND THEN WE WILL OPEN UP
TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE FIFTH.
R. L. A. ILL WHO WILL THAT BE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND STAFF IS AN
ACCESS TO INTERVIEWS THIS ITEM
AS YOU SAY- THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATION SYSTEM IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ON TO
COMPLETE THE BUILD OUT OF THAT
SYSTEM THE SYSTEM IS KNOWN AS
THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
INTEROPERABLE COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM OR LA REX- WHICH PROVIDES
BETWEEN FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
FIRST RESPONDERS. AND LW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND AS YOU STATED
MADAM CHAIR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE PROJECT
I'M IN L. A. COUNTY FAIR TO
SPEAK TO THE DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MISTER
PETERS- WE MOVE ON THEN. TO MR
EDSON. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS GOT ITS
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF L. A. RICKS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BUDGET REQUESTS. WHICH
IS A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY WITH
TEN PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONALS
ON ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS. WE
ARE REQUESTING EIGHTEEN POINT
SIX MILLION AND URGENT ONE TIME
STATE FUNDING TO ENSURE
COMPLETION OF THE OTHER X.
SYSTEM WHICH IS A STATE OF THE
ART. NEEDED A RADIO
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM FROM LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL FIRST
RESPONDERS INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRE AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL AGENCIES. PRIMARY USERS
CURRENTLY TESTING THE SYSTEM
INCLUDE THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
COUNTY FIRE VARIOUS INDEPENDENT
POLICE AGENCIES SEVERAL
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
UCLA AND OTHER PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT ENTITIES. THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES THAT SERVE
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES AND THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CURRENTLY USE A
TAX WORK OF AGING RADIO
NETWORKS. WHICH CANNOT REALLY
TALK TO ONE ANOTHER. WHICH
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY. AS AN
EXAM IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WE'RE IN PURSUIT OF
AN ARMED CARJACKING SUSPECT GOT
ON THE SIX OH FIVE FREEWAY. THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL JOINED
THE PURSUIT AND THE PURSUIT
EXITED IN THE CITY OF DOWNEY
WHERE HE WAS PITTED BY THE CHP.
AND EXITED I'M SORRY. BY THE CHP
SUSPECT EXITED THE CAR SHOT IN
THE HELICOPTER AND THEN RAN INTO
A PERSON GETS PRESSED FRONT.
GIVEN THE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS- THE MULTIPLE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE C. POLICE AND THE LOS
ANGELES CA SHERIFF. THE
RESTAURANT WAS IMMEDIATELY
SURROUNDED HOWEVER NONE OF THOSE
AGENCIES WERE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER AND
WORK. TO RESPOND TO SHARE THE
SUSPECT'S DESCRIPTION- THIS
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE DEMONSTRATES
THE ENORMOUS GAP IN
COMMUNICATIONS FOR OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS. SIMPLY PUT
DELIVERY SYSTEM ADDRESSES THIS
MAJOR INTEROP OF COMMON CATIONS
GAP BY PROVIDING A UNIFIED
NETWORK OF COMMUNICATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMPLETION OF
THE L. A. RICKS SYSTEM NOT ONLY
BENEFITS LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUT
MANY STATE AGENCIES AS WELL
INCLUDING CARILLO YES AND THE C.
H. B. THE STATE SYSTEM IS MADE
UP OF FOUR SITES WITH OUTDOOR
COVERAGE ONLY. THE ONLY RICK
SYSTEM IS MADE UP OF FIFTY EIGHT
SITES AND STATE USERS WILL BE
ABLE TO SEAMLESSLY ROW BETWEEN
THE TWO SYSTEMS. THE STATE
BENEFITS GREATLY FROM THIS
PHENOMENAL COVERAGE AN INDOOR
USE OF OUR SYSTEM. THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL DURING
ROUTINE USE AND DURING MAJOR
EVENTS EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS
ESPECIALLY SINCE L. A. COUNTY
HAS BEEN CLASSIFIED AS THE MOST
DISASTER PRONE. COUNTY IN THE
COUNTRY. YEAH WHERE X. RADIO
SYSTEM. DESIGNED TO FIFTY EIGHT
SIDES IS SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
GEOGRAPHICAL FOOTPRINT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OVER FOUR
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES. INCLUDING
THE ANGELES NATIONAL FOREST THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS AND
CATALINA ISLAND. AN ESTIMATED
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION HAS
ALREADY BEEN SPENT AND LOCAL
GRANT FUNDING AND HAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED WITH OVER 80% OF THE
L. RICS SYSTEM COMPLETED. THE
SYSTEM PROVED SUCCESSFUL WHEN
TESTED AT SEVERAL DIFFERENT
MAJOR EVENTS INCLUDING THE ROSE
PARADE AND SUPERBOWL ITSELF AYE
STADIUM IN INGLEWOOD JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO- WE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS BUILDING OF THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE ENCOUNTERED UNFORESEEN
DELAYS INCLUDING A SYSTEM
REDESIGN. AND WEATHER CONDITIONS
WILDLAND FIRES GOBERT NINETEEN A
CONTRACTOR PERFORMANCE ISSUES
WHICH OF ALL CONTRIBUTED TO THE
SHORTFALL IN FUNDING. WITHOUT
THE STATE PARTNERSHIP AND
INVESTMENT OF EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION THE L. L. A. RICH
PROJECT WILL BE FORCED TO
DEMOBILIZE BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR. THIS WOULD NEGATIVELY IN
PACK. NOT ONLY RESULT IN SYSTEM
A PRICE WITH THE A HUNDRED
DOLLARS ALREADY INTO. BUT ALSO
PREVENTING SAFETY AGENCIES CALL.
YEARS THIS LIKE. NETWORK THE
REQUEST RATING POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE PARTNERS
WILL PROVIDE CRITICALLY NEEDED
FUNDING TO COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE FINAL SIDE IN THE NETWORK
AS WELL AS FULLY TASKED. AN
OPTIMIZED THE ENTIRE NETWORK
SYSTEM TO ENSURE IT'S READY NEST
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY ONCE COMPLETED
L. A. RACE WILL PROVIDE
COMMUNICATION SERVICES FOR DAY
TO DAY OPERATIONS EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS AND FOR A LARGE
SCALE EVENTS. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT IRAQ'S THE OPERATIONAL NOW
AND FOR FUTURE EVENTS SUCH AS
WHEN PEOPLE FROM THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD COME TO LOS ANGELES FOR
THE OLYMPIC GAMES IN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. L. A. RACE IS A
UNIQUE STATE OF THE ART PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATION SYSTEM THAT
WILL BENEFIT OVER TEN MILLION
RESIDENTS THE CALLLOS ANGELES
COUNTY THEIR HOME BUT ALSO FOR
THE MILLIONS OF TOURISTS WHO
ANNUALLY COME TO VISIT. THE MANY
ATTRACTIONS LOS ANGELES HAS ARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION OF OUR BUDGET
REQUEST AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER HENSON APPRECIATE-
YOUR TESTIMONY. COM I FOR ONE
BELIEVE THIS IS ESPECIALLY THE
WAY THAT YOU PRESENTED IT AND
WHAT WE'VE HEARD IN THE PAST
SEEMS LIKE- ALMOST A NO BRAINER-
THE WHAT YOU'VE ALREADY DONE UP
TILL NOW AND- THE REMAINING-
SITES THAT NEED TO BE COMPLETED-
SEEMS LIKE A VERY REASONABLE
DIRECTION TO GO IN SO THOSE ARE
JUST MY INITIAL BASIC REMARKS.
MEANT A MEMBERS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. NO- NO COMMENTS ON
THIS I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IT
AT SOME POINT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO MAYBE THAT'S THE
NEXT BUDGET CYCLE ITEM TO LOOK
AT- GAPS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
IN IN OPERABILITY GIVEN
EVERYTHING WE'RE UP AGAINST A- I
FEEL LIKE. IN THE BAY AREA AND
THE AREA I REPRESENT THAT.
THEY'RE ALREADY THERE BUT I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING OVERALL. JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE LOWER TAKING
UP AN ITEM LIKE THIS THANK YOU.
MISTER ANDERSON IS THERE A
RESPONSE TO THE SANDERS COMMENT
AS FAR AS A CONNECTION WITH
EITHER OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
OR WHAT'S THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM
HERE. UGH UGH CONNECTION OR
POTENTIAL CONNECTION. WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA- YES HAS BUILT OUT-
THE THEIR SYSTEM THE CHRYSOSTOM
STATEWIDE I'M NOT REAL FAMILIAR
WITH OTHER COUNTIES OTHER THAN
THE COUNTIES THAT SURROUND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE RIVERSIDE- ORANGE-
AND SAMBAR DINO COUNTIES ARE
ARE- IMPROVED NETWORK
COMMUNICATIONS AND WE PLAN TO
INTERFACE WITH THEM KERN
INVENTOR OF HAVE A LITTLE WAYS
TO GO- AND BEYOND THAT I'M NOT
REAL SURE BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT- IN ROBILLARD HE IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN EVERYONE'S MINDS
TODAY AND EVERYONE'S ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR FUNDING TO ENSURE.
PUBLIC SAFETY IN OUR OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR POINT OF
THE QUESTION AND I THE GAPS THAT
YOU WERE- ALLUDING TO WERE YOU
KNOW SUGGESTING MIGHT BE THE
CASE IN SOME AREAS THAT'S ALL IT
WAS REALLY ASKING FOR IT I DO
THINK SOME. GUYS ARE PRETTY FAR
PRETTY WILL ADVANCE AND STARTED
YEARS AGO IN. IN MARIN COUNTY IT
WAS KIND OF PRECIPITATED BY A
LOCAL CRISIS- YOU KNOW ABOVE THE
LARGEST FIRE THAT IT HAPPENED IN
IN. SOME HISTORY ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO- IN WHICH HE FOUND OUT
THE HARD WAY THAT INTER
OPERABILITY WAS A PROBLEM IN YOU
KNOW DELAYS OF JUST A FEW
MINUTES OBVIOUSLY CAN CAUSE.
CATASTROPHIC THE- YOU KNOW
OUTCOMES THE YUP YOU DON'T WANT.
SO I'M I'M ALL FOR THE ITEM I
GET WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND
AGAIN I'M JUST SUGGESTING MAYBE
THEY'RE IN NOT NECESSARY MY
COUNTY BUT THERE MAY BE COUNTIES
AT. JUST AREN'T THERE YET AND WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOWCOULD HOW TO PROD THEM
ALONG. OR HELP THEM ALONG THANK
YOU.
RECEIVE VERY MUCH THE WORK THAT
YOU DO- THREE WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN UP AND
MOVING NOW TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AS REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANTS NOT. A
CONFLICT. IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO- LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU ENOUGH SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO. AND CAN
FIRST VOCAL LINE. TWENTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING DONNA THANKS FOR
VISITING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLIO DOLLAR BUDGET REQUESTS
FOR L. A. RIVER. AS DIRECTOR AT
STATED IN HIS TESTIMONY I NEEDED
CRITICAL FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THE FINAL STATE OF THE ART
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS WE
CAN ONLY BE TWENTY TWENTY BE
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. ANNEXING GOALS TO. NINE
TWENTY. IF I HAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GRANTED UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I DIDN'T SUPPORT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST JUST ONE TO
PUNCTUATE WHAT MR ANTHONY- SPOKE
ABOUT THE OLYMPICS ARE COMING
THE COMING YEAR- SOONER THAN
THAN THAN LATER- EVERY AVAILABLE
RESOURCE AT OUR DISPOSAL WILL
NEED AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
KEEP OUR RESIDENTS ARE MISTER
SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING IN. NEXT. AND
HURLING THEM FURTHER IN Q. OKAY-
IF THERE IS NO MORE A MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY OF
MEMBERS IN THE COMMENTS FOR
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR WOMEN ONE
. OKAY WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. I YEAH I MOVE
THAT WE TAKE UP THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR ALL ITEMS. ON THE LIST
THANK YOU- THE ROAD ONLY
COUNTIES BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN THE MOTIONS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION DR
BRECKSVILLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATOR AZAM HI DORADO AYE
SENATOR GROVE SENATOR CORTEZ IN.
CORTEZ III SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE. THE BILL IS
THREE ZERO OKAY. KERN VOTING IS
ALL DONE UP THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS THEY ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION YOUR
PATIENCE I WOULD CONCLUDE THAT
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE IS ADJOURNED.